- Good morning, Believe Nation!
Today's message is
Don't Stop Working.
Over to you, Bill Burr.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- I enjoy annoying people.
I don't know why.
Not like the whole crowd, obviously,
'cause then I'd be bombing.
But there's a segment that's
when I'm having the most fun.
When 80% of the crowd is loving it
and then there's that 20% just going,
just looking around like,
"How are you laughing at this?"
People don't notice.
Sometimes I can see them
and if I can figure out
what they're reacting to,
it becomes a game to see if
I can get them to yell at me
or get up and start to leave.
Other than that, 'cause there's a danger
once you put together an hour that works.
You can just stop working
and just joke.
I'll just show up, I can drink all night.
I'll walk my way through the radio.
And I just keep doing this
hour that I have memorized
and I'll be thinking about doing my taxes
as I'm doing my jokes.
But then what happens is everybody
else catches up with you.
And the next thing you know,
you're that guy onstage going
"What's up with the Carter administration?
"This is crazy."
And you become that guy.
- Too many entrepreneurs get
bored of their businesses
and they fail.
Too many entrepreneurs let the success
any success that they had in the past
be chains from them achieving more.
It happens so often.
It's crazy how much this happens.
At the start of being an entrepreneur
we leave our jobs.
We leave what most people are doing
to go off and do our own thing.
To be crazy, to be wild,
to have our own business.
Set our own rules, be our own boss.
This is how we start off.
And then you start to get some customers,
then you start to make
a little bit of money,
maybe not huge money.
Maybe you have made huge money.
But you start to make
a little bit of money.
And what happens so often
to so many entrepreneurs
is once you start making a little bit
once you find the thing that
you've made some money on
then that's all you do.
And you stop innovating
and you stop growing
and you stop building.
And you just focus on this one thing.
And that is death for an entrepreneur
because we love creating new stuff.
We love exploring.
We love trying out new things.
And as you grow and you evolve
and change as a human being
what you need to do
is bring that to your business.
Where too many entrepreneurs
get bored of their companies
because at the start they love it
'cause it's a reflection of who they are,
what they want to do.
And then as they start building it
they grow and evolve as a human being
but they don't grow and
evolve their business.
Their businesses are stuck
doing what they wanted to
do a couple of years ago.
What Evan loves doing five years ago
is not the same thing as
what Evan loves doing now.
And so as I build and
grow as a human being
I bring that to my business.
I try new things.
I like to explore.
And if you find yourself
really getting bored
then what you need to do is
pass on some of that
business to somebody else.
What I try to do in my company
is I build up a business
to the point where I can either
hand it off to somebody else
or I drop it.
Most projects that I start
by the way, don't work.
Most of the new things that
I've put out don't work.
Most of the new series we've
created for the YouTube channel
they don't work.
We've cut more series
for this YouTube channel
than most people ever create
'cause it didn't work.
A combination of maybe I'm not
as passionate about it anymore
and you guys didn't like it either.
So we dropped it.
That's okay, that's good.
And so most of the things
that I tried to start,
I'll put my own energy and effort into.
Just me.
When I started a YouTube
channel, it was just me.
It was just me.
And I had no lights and no microphone
and a really bad camera.
It was just me.
And I built it to the point
where I was able to make
some money off of it.
And then I hired somebody and
then I hired another person,
I hired another person.
Built up a team.
But most projects for me
don't even go that way.
Most projects, I try build it up
and it doesn't get
anywhere and so I drop it.
Move on to something else.
But that experimentation is key.
You can't stop working.
You can't stop building.
You can't stop evolving in your company.
If you are bored right now.
Most entrepreneurs look to
I need to sell this business
and go do something else.
It's because you've let
it get so far apart.
The person that you were
when you started the business
and the person that you've now become
and you haven't brought
your business with you.
You've gotten so far apart
that you're ready to leave
it and do something else.
Find a way to inject the
new self into your business
and make it catch up with you constantly.
And if there are things
that you don't enjoy anymore
and you don't want to do.
But still add a lot of value
and still make money, great.
Hire somebody on your team
who loves doing that work.
And give it to them.
And if you can't afford
to hire somebody to do it.
Then stop it.
Kill that project 'cause it's
not financially worth it.
If you're doing projects that
is not making enough money
to hire somebody else to do
and you don't want to do it anymore,
then just drop it.
And start working on
the work that you love
'cause that's where you're
going to come alive.
That's where you're going to create magic.
You need to evolve with your business.
Look at a great band like The Beatles.
Maybe the greatest band of all time.
Their first album was not the
same as their second album
was not the same as their third album.
The reason why they had
so much sustainability
was because they evolved their business
as they evolved as human beings.
If they stuck to just doing
the same album every time
they would be a one-album wonder.
And nobody would pay
attention to them anymore.
But as they grew and as they evolved.
Their business grew and
evolved around them.
And so who do you want to be?
Do you want to be The Beatles
or do you want to be a one-hit wonder?
Time to decide.
So the question of the
day today is, I'm curious.
How have you evolved
your business with you?
I'm curious,
from when you started your business
to where you are now.
How have you grown and how
have you introduced new things
into your company?
I'm really curious to find out.
Please leave it down the comments below.
And we'll join in on the discussion.
I also want to give a quick
shout to Steven Ratson.
Steven, thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book, Your One Word.
It really really really means a lot to me
and I hope you're enjoying it.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself.
And whatever your one word is,
much love and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
Hey, Believe Nation.
Thank you so much for watching.
If you want to learn
more about this subject,
get a little bit deeper on it.
I'm going to share some extra bonus clips
that I hope you'll enjoy.
- Why do you still care enough to keep,
you're at a point in your life
where you could go back.
You could do your month in Vegas,
and Florence Henderson could open up
and you could go and hit a couple of balls
and then some pinball.
Why do you still care so much?
- Well, I'm not comparing myself
to any of these people, believe me.
But you wouldn't say to Picasso.
"When are you going to
put those brushes down?
"Get rid of the canvas, you've done it."
I'm an entertainer, first and foremost,
but there's art involved here.
And an artist has an
obligation to be on root.
To be going somewhere.
There's a journey involved here.
And you don't know where
it is and that's the fun.
So you're always going to be
seeking and looking and going
and trying to challenge yourself.
So without sitting around
and thinking of that a lot,
it drives you and it keeps you
trying to be fresh, trying to be new,
trying to call on yourself.
Call on yourself a little more.
- And I think some of that is just,
well first of all if you do very well
and you make a lot of money,
when you look back on your experiences
and running a company
or starting a company.
And there's almost a
kind of disbelief in like
how did I, did I really go through that?
Did I really deal with all of that pain
and headache and hassle and intensity?
And this is one of the reasons
why people who are founders
are often so bonded together
like people who've gone to war.
They'll never forget those experiences.
But to get up and do that again
over and over again
knowing full well
each time exactly what's in store for you.
I think that is more rare
and it definitely requires
that you're not willing
to rest on your laurels.
I can't sit back and say,
okay I've founded a bunch of companies.
They've been tremendously successful.
Therefore all my companies
are going to be successful.
I have to be as paranoid
and as edgy about each new company.